en france florian philippot fois donné
rendez vous à ses partisans devant le
sénat cet après midi chez le chef de
file des patriotes a été rejoint dans le
6e arrondissement de paris par de
nombreux opposants à la propose la
proposition de loi elle sur l'obligation
vaccinale est soumis par les socialistes
ce projet de loi sera débattu dans
l'hémicycle demain le but de cette
proposition atteindra l'immunité
collective
florian philippot qui déploie entre
autres le manque de recul sur les
vaccins utilisés dans le pays écoutez le
[Musique]
par ailleurs et nous avait vendu
la liberté est au bout de la seringue
la liberté c'est la vaccination on
entend ça tous les matins la radio et
elle est partout
on n'existe pas ailleurs la vérité la
transparence totale sur les effets
secondaires du vaccin ce que nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui notamment le
nombre de myocardite notamment chez les
jeunes nous exigeons cette vérité c'est
notre choix c'est l'autre chantait c'est
notre vie ce n'est pas leur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]